okay there have been a number of
different of very attention garnering
posts to my Instagram account you can
find me on instagram at david pakman and
i hope you'll follow me there last week
on the bonus show we talked about the
st. patrick's day parade that takes
place here in boston and specifically in
my neighborhood of South Boston and I
talked about on the bonus show how I
generally don't like the parade because
it brings all sorts of people littering
and and there's a lot of public
urination and stuff like that I couldn't
have possibly predicted how bad it was
going to be this year and I sent the
following email we have an intra
building where I live mailing list and I
posted this to my Instagram account and
the email I had to send out had the
subject people urinating all over and I
wrote to my fellow neighbors hey did
anyone notice the dozens of people
urinating in our recycling and trash
area as well as between our building and
the next building over on the air
conditioning units and whatnot I'm doing
what I can to scare them off it's bad
and the most common reaction to this pat
was David when you said you're doing
what you can to scare them off could you
explain what it is that you're doing and
a lot of people wondering what that
meant did you go out there with a broom
or something I'm glad you are the front
door I'm going to address this on the
bonus show today on the bonus show i am
going to enumerate the specific things i
did to try to scare public urinate errs
away from my building okay so it's less
to say it's going to be a doozy of a
bonus show today yeah I mean the thing
is I understand you're drinking a lot of
beer and this is an outdoor event so
there's nowhere to really relieve
yourself right but to do so in the
recycling bin I mean well nowhere to
reveal yourself other than to dozens and
dozens of restaurants lining the parade
route but that'll be part of the story
for the bonus show also popular on my
Instagram account again follow me there
david pakman i posted a this is sort of
a pilot project since we launched david
pakman show Koffee many viewers and
listeners have been demanding david
pakman show coffee mugs to sort of bring
the entire thing full circle i got one
sample coffee mug with our logo made and
i posted it to my Instagram account I
also have it here with the David Pakman
logo
so on both sides i'll take a sip
delicious and we are we are thinking pat
about launching these the problem is
they're kind of expensive and i don't
know how much people would be willing to
pay for a mug and for it to be worth it
we've got to make a little bit of money
on it and the costs on them are
relatively high so we need to figure out
what people would be willing to pay for
something like this I think people would
put out the money though for that
because it really just does bring the
experience together it's like drinking a
beer out of a glass made specifically
for that beer yes it is sort of like
that yeah what else can I say that's
that's sort of exactly what it's like so
what let me know if you would be
interested in mugs like this and what
they should cost and i'll see if we can
make it happen and of course follow me
on instagram i'm on instagram at david
pakman